well it's three years since I was last
in Kylie reporting then on the
bulldozing of an area called the jungle
and the outskirts of this port city that
was an attempt by the authorities to
address a growing problem of illegal
immigrants trying to get across to the
UK hundreds were camped in this area
called the jungle they bulldozed it but
now more than three years on it seems
that the problem of illegal immigration
and those migrants trying to get across
to the UK is as bad as it ever was we
are told that there are now around 400
illegal immigrants here in Cali trying
to get across on the ferries that you
see behind us they try to smuggle
themselves on board the many lorries
that are part up here waiting to get on
to the ferries or through the Channel
Tunnel to the UK there's a soup kitchen
that has been set up by a number of the
local charities here to help out the
immigrants who are from countries like
Somalia South Sudan Eritrea Syria of
course because of the problems in that
country at the moment many of them have
no means of supporting themselves so
they really rely on these soup kitchens
that the charities are operating and now
of course since they've cleared the
jungle as well what we're finding in
Cali itself is that people are setting
up their encampments their makeshift
tents right smack bang in the middle of
this port that is a problem of course
that the authorities here will have to
tackle in the coming weeks and months
ahead as they realize that the
immigration problem here seems to be as
bad as it ever was